OR E-MAIL.
>> TOMORROW IT PRESIDENTS'
DAY, 45 INDIVIDUALS HAVE
HELD THAT OFFICE, 545
MILLION PEOPLE HAVE LIVED IN
THIS COUNTRY SINCE WE BECAME
A COUNTRY.
ONLY 45 MEN FOR NOW, HAVE
EVER BEEN CALLED PRESIDENT.
WHAT DO YOU THINK WHEN YOU
REFLECT ON THOSE 45 MEN?
HOW MANY DO YOU THINK DID A
GOOD JOB?
WHAT ARE YOUR EXPECTATIONS
FOR A PRESIDENT?
TO WE WANT THE PERSON WHO IS
BEST ON POLICIES?
MOST LIKELY TO FIND
CONSENSUS?
OR MOST PERSUASIVE?
SOMEONE WE CAN RELATE TO?
OR SOMEONE THAT APPEARS
LARGER THAN LIFE.
LIFE?
A MORAL LEADER, A BUSINESS
MIND, A PUBLIC SPEAKER, TO
WE WANT A PRESIDENT WHO
TELLS US WHAT WE WANT TO
HEAR OR SOMEONE THAT TELLS
US THE TRUTH, EVEN IF IT DID
NOT WHAT WE WANTED TO HEAR.
THERE IS CONSENSUS GEORGE
WASHINGTON, ADAMS AND
JEFFERSON.
I ADMIRED LINCOLN BECAUSE OF
ALL HE OVERCAME TO LEAD US
DURING
THE DIVISIVE TIME -- HE
SEEMED HUMBLE, AND RONALD
REAGAN WAS HOPEFUL, AND HE
EXPERIENCE DEFEAT IN LIFE
BUT HE CAME BACK TO BECOME
ONE OF OUR MOST BELOVED
PRESIDENTS, MY GRANDFATHER
LIKED ROOSEVELT.
MAYBE WE WANT A PRESIDENT WE
CAN LIKE?
AMERICA STILL MOURNS WHAT
COULD HAVE BEEN WITH JOHN F.
KENNEDY THAT WAS A LOSS FROM
WHICH PERHAPS WE'LLER IN
RECOVER.
AND -- WE'LL NEVER RECOVER,
ONLY TWO PRESIDENTS HAVE
RECEIVED MORE THAN 55% OF
VOTE IN MY
LIFETIME, 5 WERE ELECTED
PRESIDENT WITH LESS THAN 50%
OF THE POPULAR VOTE, THINK
ABOUT, THAT WE'VE NOT HAD A
CONSENSUS LEADER IN 50
YEARS.
THERE HAVE BEEN MORE
IMPEACHMENTS IN MY LIFETIME
THAN LANDSLIDE PRESIDENTIAL
WINNERS, ON THE DAY WE SET
ASIDE TO HONOR PRESIDENTS,
PERHAPS IT IS WISE TO ASK
ARE THE EXPECTATIONS WE HAVE
FOR OUR PRESIDENTS
REASONABLE?
DO THE RIGHT WOMEN AND MEN
SEEK THAT OFFICE?
HOW TO WE JUDGE THE
SUCCESSES OF A PRESIDENT.
WHAT WOULD IT TAKE TO FIND
SOMEONE TO PERHAPS 75% OF US
COULD RALLY AROUND.
WHAT WOULD IT TAKE TO FIND A
WOMAN OR A MAN WHO GENERATED
REAL CONSENSUS?
SOMEONE WITH A REAL MANDATE
TO LEAD THE NATION?
IF WE ARE AN EXCEPTIONAL
COUNTRY, SHOULDN'T WE HAVE
EXCEPTIONAL LEADERS?
HOW MANY OF OUR PRESIDENTS
WOULD YOU DESCRIBE AS
EXCEPTIONAL?
MAYBE THE BEST WAY TO SPEND
PRESIDENTS' DAY IS TO
REFLECT ON WHAT IT IS WE'RE
LOOKING FOR IN A PRESIDENT.
DOES THE PROCESS OF SEEKING
THAT WAS ON THE ENCOURAGE
THE CALIBER OF WOMEN AND
MENU MOST WANT TO RUN AND
SERVE?
I GUESS THE THING I ASK
MYSELF ON THIS PRESIDENTS'
DAY IS A SIMPLE QUESTION.
IF WE STRUGGLE TO FIND
PRESIDENTS WE LIKE AND
RESPECT, DOES THAT SAY MORE
ABOUT US OR THEM?
THERE IS A DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN BEING A PRESIDENT
AND A LEADER.
MAYBE THE PROCESS, POLITICAL
ENVIRONMENT, MEDIA HAVE MADE
IT SUCH THAT REAL LEADERS DO
NOT WANT THIS JOB.
WE'RE LEFT WITH THOSE WHO
COVET THE TITLE.
WHILE WE AS A NATION ARE
LEFT TO COVET REAL LEADERS.
I DON'T KNOW IN WASHING ON
.
>> I KNOW THAT GREAT PEOPLE
SHOULD HAVE GREAT LEADERS.
IF THOSE GREAT LEADERS ARE
NO